Cũng về và tối qua thành phố Huy Chíming đã khảnh thành công viên tưởng nghiệm là nhân của biết mẹ chiến sau mạh tháng thi công.
Nằm tưởng nghiệm 2.8 in người đã mất tại thành phố Huy Chíming.
Tham dự lẽ thành thành có đồng chi trên lưu quan, huy vien của chính trị, mí thư thành huy thành phố Huy Chíming.
Hù đất số mồ tí thái tổ, dòng muốn về mấy mì sợ hết ta, lưu glời trọng để kiến tạo công viên.
Dự án có tổn bức lưu tương 2, 2, 3 bà tỷ đồng. Thực hiện thông in thức sợ hội hoa,
và hoàn thành nháng trọng chỉ trong chính như ngày đêm.
Điểm nhấn là khoảng trường giật nước, giật một tảm chân mệt mồn với tượng đại giật nước,
biểu tượng của sự sống và cũng là giật nước mắt của mặt mắt.
Bình trọng giật nước là hình trái tim, hợi nhắc đến tình người trong những ngày giản khó.
Công viên được tiếp kiếc trên tình thần màu tôn tối ra không raen xanh,
kết thở thài hoa, giữa cạnh quan, xin hoa tục lâu và khu tự nghiệp.